the most dangerous room in the house is
the bathroom a report released by the
CDC in 2008 stated that 22 million
Americans every year get injured right
here in the bathroom so here's my
scientific evidence-based grooming
routine to keep you safe and happy and
healthy huge thanks to Tao for
sponsoring this video all right let's
get started
PE okay first things first we got to
shower and the last time I talked about
advice surrounding showers I got a lot
of flack not everyone needs to shower
every single day your whole video smell
like hot dog water and wet pan here's
the reality not everybody needs to
shower every single day and showering
with extremely hot water is not great
for your skin it predisposes you to all
sorts of rashes irritations it dries out
your skin so when we're talking showers
we're talking quick less than 5 minutes
not not incredibly hot and not
necessarily every day 2/3 of those 22
million accidents that happen in the
bathroom each here happen as a result of
slip and Falls that's why it's so
important that there's something for you
to grab on to in your shower and that
you have good grip on the floor that can
mean putting in a shower mat or just
installing grip tape so that you have
good traction it's time to lather up
with the soap bar and a fun fact about
your soap bar is that it does does in
fact have bacteria on it even though
soap is antibacterial pretty weird
process but the amount of bacteria found
on your soap is pretty limited there's
not enough of it to cause a problem and
the second you start using it the water
runs through it it cleans off the
bacteria no problem now much like
showering you don't have to shampoo
every day this is of course unless you
have fine hair live in a humid
environment or sweating a lot otherwise
it's perfectly fine to go a few days
without shampooing your head when you do
shampoo make sure that you clean your
scalp well cuz part of washing your hair
is also washing your scalp one of the
most common shampoo questions I get is
about twoin one products where you have
shampoo plus conditioner now unless
you're in a pinch this is not advisable
to be used daily in order to have the
conditioner actually stay on after you
shampoo you need the conditioner to be a
special formulation to withstand some of
that shampoo power the degreasing power
and as a result if you use that day in
and day out you can actually have a
buildup of Grease weighing your hair
down making it look less than optimal
we've talked about cleaning hair but now
let's talk about getting rid of hair now
I'm not usually one to shave but I will
point out that most people when they do
shave they shave incorrectly when you do
so you can create Nicks in your skin
irritation acne foliculitis which is an
infected hair follicle literally just
learning proper shaving technique by
following these simple steps will go a
long way in decreasing shaving
irritation and because I don't shave and
I still want to maintain a kept
appearance I do trim my facial hair when
I do the trimming I usually clean up my
beard all the way to the edge of my
jawline just for a little bit of
accentuation now let's talk nose hair
it's unsightly people want to get rid of
it there's videos on Tik Tok of people
ripping out their nose hairs using waxes
people plucking it and that's not really
medically ideal because nose hair is is
there to serve a purpose it actually
acts as a filtering system for your nose
so instead of ripping it out either by
plucking or waxing use a nose hair
trimmer to gently trim it so that you
don't see it on the outside of your nose
moving on to armpit hair most people
will make their choice on whether or not
they want to have armpit hair based on
Aesthetics the way that it looks for me
the way that I like to think about it is
it's there to serve a purpose part of
that purpose is to decrease friction
especially if you're exercising off
often if you're moving your arms you're
swinging them by your sides having the
armpit hair will actually decrease some
of that chafing and irritation that can
come as a result of jogging however
there are certain instances where
individuals can struggle with their Boo
or body odor and in those instances
getting rid of the armpit hair could be
beneficial and actually cut down on that
smell pubic hair Simple Solution on this
one trimming is the way to go we've seen
all sorts of medical research even the
ones that I talked about in this video
here about the fact that when you shave
you create openings in skin and that's a
simple way to transmit an STI also we
just said it for armpits friction
reduction is important especially in the
nether region and when you are going to
be trimming your hair use different
trimmers for the right task for example
for my face I have this wall facial hair
trimmer so it has sharper edges it's a
little bit cleaner can get closer to the
skin but then when you're doing your
pubic area you're doing your chest hair
use one that has a skin safety blade
like this otherwise you could get really
bad cuts and uh that will make it a lot
more tolerable and safe I'm someone who
tends to sweat a lot so let's talk about
how to stop sweating or at least for the
sweat to be not as smell we have two
options when it comes to that
antiperspirant and deodorant the
difference between the two is quite
simple anti-perspirant blocks pores
preventing you from sweating and
deodorant actually just kills the
bacteria in your armpits and applies a
fresh scent so that your sweat doesn't
smell I like to say that there's two
types of sweat you have Thermo
regulation sweat where you're trying to
cool your body down and then there is
stress sweat which comes from your
apocrine glands there's more protein
more oil in this type of sweat so when
bacteria begin to consume it they
release a smell that is not incredibly
Pleasant and if you happen to be one of
those individuals like myself who has
hyperhydrosis sweats intensely profusely
there's a couple of strategies one you
can get a clinical strength
antiperspirant that ideally you put on
on the day before the night before when
your body's at its coolest so that it
does the most effective job at plugging
your pores another option kicking into
high gear and getting an injection of
Botox directly into your axillary or
armpit sweat glans that will shut them
down therefore decreasing sweating hair
drying is one of the most important
parts of a proper grooming routine
because you want to do it smart so that
you're not damaging your hair for me
something I do before styling my hair is
putting in a light moisturizing cream
and thickening spray we've actually seen
through science that when your hair is
wet it's the most susceptible to being
damaged keeping your scalp damp for a
long time can increase the growth of
fungus or bacteria I really recommend
towel drying first and then using a
moderate heat setting on a blow dryer in
order to get it dry but making sure
you're doing it the right way at least 6
in apart away from your hair not direct
heat I recently got the tyo air hype
dryer and I really like it because of
its incredibly powerful motor more power
in the motor means less drying time less
exposure to heat less damage to my hair
it's kind of a win-win across the board
it can even penetrate thick hair to dry
your scalp and hair quickly it's
powerful enough to dry a full head of
long hair in 30 minutes but my hair
isn't that long so I'm usually done in
under five use a moderate heat setting
to dry hair gently as to never burn your
scalp or fry your hair reminder that
when you use a traditional dryer they
can heat up while you're using them
which bakes your hair and hair breakage
is most commonly caused by heat damage
the timeo feels incredibly high-end you
have a screen here that pops up the fan
speed the temperature setting uh it's
very easy to turn on the cool setting I
really like the giant features in the
tyo uh like the negative ion built-in
system which actually neutralizes the
positive charges in wet hair therefore
decreasing frizz an underrated feature
of the timeo is the fact that it's
incredibly quiet at at only 69 DB uh
that's a lot better than some of the
leading competitors that I've used in
the past I've said time and time again
the less noise you have at high DB near
your ear the better given the quality
the tech the fact that this works on so
many different hair types it's a great
gift for just about anybody so click the
link in the description you're going to
get a discount highly highly recommend
the tyo air hype blow dryer once my hair
is dry I like to use no rebbe molding
paste in order to to get it styled I
think this product looked semi matat
more natural and it washes out quite
easily as well you don't have any
leftover Gunk after the
shower nails are the window to your
health I can tell you how many times I
examine my patient nails to find a
serious health condition going on
whether it's certain things that point
to an autoimmune condition like sertic
nails or perhaps a black line on the
nails that signifies a melanoma that's a
skin cancer that develops under the nail
it's really important to not only take
good care of your nails but also to
speak with your doctor if something
happens that's unusual for your nail uh
part of my grooming routine is making
sure my nails are cut short it's ideal
to do this after the shower because your
nails are softer then it's easier to cut
them fun fact toenails do grow slower
than fingernails so you can get away
with cutting them less often there are
instances especially if you wear tight
fitting Footwear that you can get an
ingrown toenail folks do try and make
incisions In Their Skin and their nail
to try and treat this if you're unsure
instead of doing damage see your doctor
cuz what we actually do is cut out that
part of the nail after numbing the toe
and then we actually destroy the base of
the nail where the nail Matrix is in
order to prevent that part of the nail
from regrowing back and causing another
problem can't have a grooming routine
without talking about dental health and
dental health is a part of Health it
starts by brushing your teeth you should
be doing this ideally twice a day
because you want to get rid of plaque
plaque buildup leads to gingivitis gum
disease cavities oral health problems
that you simply do not want and brushing
your teeth is a simple way to combat
that when it comes to flossing there's a
little bit of controversy to be had
because people say that there is no
long-term data saying that flossing is
actually beneficial but while there is
no long-term randomized Control Data
there are really good quality short-term
data that support flossing and also
there's a ton of anecdotal good quality
evidence across the globe that safe
lossing is an important part of Health
when it comes to mouthwash it's a common
question I get and unless it's
specifically recommended for you by a
dentist by a doctor for some specific
medical condition I usually tell most
people to avoid mouthwash because they
usually use one that has a lot of
alcohol in it that aims to kill all
bacteria in the mouth but remember part
of your microbiome is probiotic meaning
it's good bacteria and you don't want to
kill it if you brush your teeth and you
floss you should have a healthy smelling
mouth if you don't then you should be
speaking to your doctor about other
causes that can cause bad breath or
hosis like acid reflux that's a
surprising one most people don't know
about it's probably pretty shocking too
that I even have these in my home but
Q-tips have a wide variety of uses that
I actually enjoy the place where I would
tell you not to put these is inside your
ear if you want to use a Q-tip to clean
your ear clean the outside of the ear
only so many of my patients think that
ear wax means a dirty ear but that's not
true in fact if you remove all your ear
wax from your ear you dry out the canal
Faster by scratching inside the ear you
make it more prone to bacterial
infections fungal infections and if you
go far enough with a Q-tip you could
actually damage your eard drum or tanic
membrane also if you are going to be
using this anywhere around your ear make
sure you're not doing it near door
when it comes to skin care I like to
keep things as simple as possible and
the advice here really needs to be
individualized for my skin that's
perpetually dry I like to use a
moisturizing product that's good quality
I like this bioderma product if I'm
applying a moisturizer and I know I'm
going to be spending time outside I like
to get one with SPF in it that also
means getting a good quality lip balm as
well especially if you're a mouth
breather cuz your nose is a little
stuffy at night making sure your lips
are dry goes a long long way to prevent
chapping currently I have a situation
where I have a a little rosacea around
my eye so for that I'm using
metronidazol which uniquely is an
antibiotic not that this is an
infectious process or that this helps
because of its antibiotic properties the
idea is that it has some
anti-inflammatory properties but I've
been using it and so far it's been doing
a decent job hopefully this rosacea will
go I don't usually use a cleansing
product unless unless I've just done
television or the news where they put on
foundation and makeup on my face against
my will and when they do I want to make
sure that I clean that off properly so I
do use a cleansing product at that time
but in general I don't think it's
mandatory to every day to cleanse your
face you've seen my grooming routine but
have you seen Bear's grooming routine
click here to check it out and as always
stay happy and
[Music]
healthy